vanessa murphy is tracking shortages in
our area hospitals
but first sasha loftis breaks down the
vaccination program that is expected to
begin
in just days sasha kirsten and david the
112 page document details exactly how
the first doses of the covid19 vaccine
will be distributed
here in nevada through this month the
month of december
it's a three-tier system the first round
of vaccines will come to about 164
thousand
they will go to front-line workers and
hospitals those who live and work in
nursing homes
and other members of our most vulnerable
populations
91 000 of those vaccines will get the
will come from pfizer rather
while just over 72 thousand will receive
the moderna vaccine
as we've reported they are only
effective when received in two separate
doses
the shots will be given three to four
weeks apart depending on the brand
the state expects to get through the
tier one vaccines by january
and then it will expand to its second
and third phases
now it is important to note state
leaders say supply may be limited at
first but the vaccine will be available
to everyone who wants and needs it
the general population is expected to
have access by the spring or the summer
now coming up at six o'clock we'll
explain further who will be part of
phases two and three
of that vaccine process as the
distributions process begins